what's the most important part of the
cinematographer's job
i think the most important part for a
cinematographer
is his relationship with the director
and basically as a cinematographer you
are there to facilitate the director's
dream
so
you know i think it's very important to
have a point of view that you bring to
it
in other words you've read the script
you you see the the movie in a certain
way
uh one of the first things i like to do
with a director that i'm about to work
with is to
uh get in the screening room and watch
some of the movies that we think are
like relevant to the one that we're
doing or
or his favorite movies and i bring the
same thing to the uh
to the party so that we that we
watch other movies and uh we
come to uh
a symbiosis of
the way we're going to treat the
material because very often
on the set that everything's moving so
fast that you can't
you know you can't have that kind of
artistic collaboration
because the actors are out there you go
to light it and you know you got someone
screaming at you
you've been lighting that for seven and
a half minutes come on we gotta
we gotta go so uh in the heat of battle
um you can't necessarily have the the
the the kind of collaboration that you
would like
but you need to have set that up ahead
of time and
um that is your job is to is to bring a
visual um
[Music]
a visual flare to the story but at the
same time
um you're there to facilitate the
director's vision
speaking of battle we hear sometimes
that
a cinematographer and a director will
clash and the cinematographer will say
i need this sort of this isn't going to
work
both to have a different agenda what
advice would you recommend to new
directors
and if they're in that spot and how do
they take it
away from the set i realize at times
it's going to be chaos you're not going
to be able to fight it
and you probably don't want to do it in
front of a crew but but if
faced with that dilemma which we've
definitely heard from a lot of people or
or you know just a clashing how do you
take that away from the set
and just try to make it through the
entire production
well um you know there was a reason that
you were chosen in the first place so
there must be
there must be you know unless you're a
new director in the studio said hey
we're going to put this old-time
cinematographer on your show and
he's going to make sure that you finish
it in 21 days you know
so there is that which and that's very
hard for a young director to
to work with but you know let's assume
that's not
happening and you know the director's
chosen you and you're
you're working on his project and
something does blow up that's exactly
what you do is you just
take them on and say hey let's take this
outside you know and
you have whatever that discussion is
going to be away from the set because
[Music]
you know public uh errands airing of
grievances
has no place on a set for me sure
and last question in the same vein uh
someone left a comment which i thought
was interesting
and they said if you are either a dp or
a director
make sure you have some people in your
own camp
on set with you so that the production
doesn't run away
to somebody else's side and everybody
kind of turns
so do you have a core set of people you
always like to work with
not just for that that
possible problem but it was something i
had never thought of never having been
in that situation
but they said to always have some people
quote in your own camp because
things could quickly turn and then
somehow the production gets away from
one of the two well i'd say earlier in
my career i lost
jobs because i didn't have that core
crew
and you know the producer wanted to hire
somebody that
had his gaffering or you know everybody
in place and they were a well
oiled machine that could come to work on
his picture
you know um
working for years and years as a
commercial
director cameraman i was
i had a different kind of most most
commercial directors they they're with a
company
and every time they go out they use
exactly the same people
i had a slightly different business
model in that i was a freelance director
so i would go out to like regional
advertising
and i'd go to a new city and i'd have to
put a whole production together from
scratch
and in that situation i used to
maybe only be able to take like one guy
with me
and uh but i always i
i didn't always get that one guy but um
[Music]
uh i think it is really important you
know
and i actually used to take
uh my key grip which people thought was
unusual people who always say oh he's
gonna take his gaffer you know
or this because uh and
i used to i renamed him from key grip to
crew chief which is that motor racing
term
and it's really that the guy that runs
the whole physical
operation and he used to he used to work
for me in
in that area and that would let me deal
with the agency and the actors and
and the and the cinema so i think
i think crew members are very very
important that you have that shorthand
with that person um that you can get
things done very quickly you know
and time is the enemy you know so is it
almost like being in war
uh well i think it's much more pleasant
i would imagine um
but it is you know they're that they're
uh there are uh
there's a lot of money at stake and um
you know um showing up
is the first rule
so um being on time on a set is like
is my number one rule and i probably got
that from being so arrogant about it
when i was a kid you know
uh but the curt you know from the from
the moment you arrive on a set
the clock is ticking and i i hear that
i hear the dollar bills dropping you
know and um
so um
i think it's um a strategy
that you in other words you have to have
a battle plan
to go into your day shoot and you have
to have everything worked out to the nth
degree in other words when i do a
schedule
it's you know it's it it's every 10
minutes so
10 minutes in i'm doing this you know
so because i i often get to other
people's sets and people are
like they're in the makeup trailer and
they're like they're having a cup of
coffee and
you know and nothing's nothing's
happening you know
so for me the very first thing that you
do is you get the actors out on the set
and you block the first scene
they're not i don't care if they're in
makeup or what but the moment they
arrive on the set we block the first
scene
um so it's very important to have that
battle plan
to work with but then you've got to be
prepared to
completely throw that away if
either creativity or necessity
takes you off in another direction so
you've always you've always got to have
a plan b
and you've always got to be able to punt
if for
if things go in a different direction so
be totally prepared and then be prepared
to give it all up
you know
you